the Joe Rogan experience trained by khow
podcast by night
[Music]
she been on the road not really leaving
a little bit here and there and start
back to Baltimore
oh that's out like it was fun later for
the UFC so okay oh yeah thanks for the
offer on our land of fun dismissed you
there we we were out of there about four
days before you it was great stuff well
you know that guy cow head in Tampa okay
break did so he he decided he's
indicating so he decided to change his
name to his real name's Mike alte so
your accountant right right I think I
got well so they did a roast for him as
it was a benefit but the idea was dead
that's answer to everybody was saying
like this is your only fucking equity in
life did you know and so sue me
Jim Norton Bert Kreischer Florentine
Bobby Kelly we all flew down for it no
shit yeah but they said you know come
down and bring your family will be
tickets to every theme park which they
did that's a scratch so so we went to
Universal Disney Busch Gardens all look
like those Fast Pass where you go in
front of my oh I've got a great hotel
Lewis oven it was great and then my
sister was down in Florida visiting my
mom so then we just we made a vacation I
spent a week at my mom after that so
it's a good trip yeah but I I fuckin
tweaked my neck on some relics puzzlers
did you ruin my knees
Busch Gardens is like if you're into
roller coasters it's they've got like a
dozen of the most hardcore roller
coasters
like 400 foot straight drops and
corkscrews and you know and I was into
it but then on the second to last one I
felt something and then I spent at my
mom's house and literally this this is
my rotation entire week at my mom's
house man I went to the chiropractor
twice if that ever happens forget the
chiropractor boat get deep tissue
massage
yeah loosen up the soft tissue that's
almost all but really yeah I mean and
I've come through a series of back
injuries over the last year
and one of the things that I found a lot
of chiropractic is bullshit the
lightening and not really recognized by
science or medicine either it's a broad
word that's not even one type of
chiropractor you get guys that do all
different times yet yeah the guy once he
wasn't great I just felt like I needed
something I was gonna get massaged just
too weird to do that with my sting of my
mom no therapeutic he read someone do
that yeah if she's light it's great but
some of these fucking cows they're you
know they're 50 years old and they put
on a few pounds a weird thing
random take a lot of head impacts they
start getting depressed and inside so
the dirty secret of combats Orchestra
that most of those guys when you hear
all that positive talk it's not just to
pump themselves up for fights it's to to
try to push away the demons sure that
are in their consciousness because of
depression and there's another thing
that goes along with that a lot of times
they're rather combative and argumented
that's a way of getting serotonin levels
going I am creating some type of a
little argumentum thing and then you get
like all the company hormones that go
along with the argument of nature yeah
like me right now I come on fire it up
about this fuck yeah yeah but luckily
you didn't take the punches to the head
like yeah no yeah there's no punches to
the bed when I was just reasoning today
about this whole dirty drug thing going
on the NFL how they just pumped these
guys pull up painkillers for years and
I'll here lidocaine oh yeah
percocet everything the vicodin and
having just on and on and on just tons
of this stuff and these guys are
suffering renal failure
terrific horrific horrific stuff I mean
I don't know if you had a son but you
want him to play for I would not well I
would rather have him fight I'd have my
kid fuck cuz I need your kids yeah judo
any day over football and you could
fight intelligently you could have a
good camp let's just we could talk about
down the podcast yeah that's actually
good um but let's do it Jamie yeah I
mean it's brutal
yeah and now there's like over 500
players suing the NFL yeah let's talk
about that let's talk about that
changed this is this is this is so right
I see the way it's curved so you can
only pull that with one I can pull it
with your right yes yeah yeah this is a
stabilizer attach this on to it nicely
also stabilize this so this is their
site floors
yeah yeah this is the stabilizer this
sort of helps you balance it out while
you're shooting and then this why should
i here when it's the site yeah this is
no joke
well my thought is if you're going
hunting you what it really helped me
yeah you really should use the most
powerful thing that you can and the
issue really is that a lot of people
think you know hey you know you don't
need that kind of power and they there's
a lot of criticism in the the Bo
community the archer community of people
who use like really heavy pound bows
they think that you know you're being a
meathead and it's not necessary in your
your over bowed you know you don't need
that much bow but I've kind of thought
that through it I think what's a regular
guy what was strong to a regular guy is
not that strong to person who loose a
lot of weight
yeah for sure strength is relatively
yeah for me to use a 90 pound book and a
guy who's weak to use a sixty like why
does he think that that this is harder
for me to use than it is for any use of
sixty like if you don't lift a lot of
weights yeah so but it's so weird like
these it's weird this ego thing that
goes on this weird criticism thing like
that's old that's great
you don't need that why do you use that
you don't need a but I really think it's
because they can't do it so they have
this weird thing they're happy I
personally wouldn't want that though
that would be as powerful as I could
possibly pull that well come on over
here I'll show you some got divorced in
maiming and in takes it out
the cards that I put the site tape on is
that what this is for New York yeah this
is from here right from this tree is
pretty far offered no real authority
arms if the cheerleader is any movement
at all this is his we're indoor yeah
there's a lot of charm here
so what's a really long shotgun what's a
really long shot I mean what's
considered a long shot oh you have to be
a real real mark a real Archer yeah
[Music]
I'll do this for hours once I get home
this is kind of summative kind of at the
end of it yeah once you get we just hit
the swing of it it's kind of it's so
interesting that when you're
concentrating on the shop once you're
locked in the word will goes away
[Music]
[Applause]